[Music]
okay i understand it's a difficult
moment for you but we have power
failures throughout the ship then i want
you i don't work for you
and i don't work for anderson doors i
gave the order to fire
you know we had to do it
if we hadn't the industry if you've
killed them hate me later
work now as we get closer to the end of
the year we're taking a look at the most
fearless women on tv from deep space
battles to the living dead and beyond
these characters stood out for being
inspiring and brave in the face of
challenges so we're shedding light on
these incredible women and shows as we
count down the most fearless women on tv
[Music]
starting with number 10 women of the
walking dead who can slice through
mobile meat sacks with the greatest of
ease these women who watch his friends
and family die but still returns to the
fight these warriors and who fights
zombie hordes week after week seemingly
without breaking a sweat the women of
the walking dead maggie michonne and
carol are just three characters who have
proven their zombie whacking prowess on
the amc horror series over its 10 season
run it must feel good to be so badass
we need the food
i was hoping you might send enough to
tide them over while we figure this out
we could do it
we have the surpluses yeah but for how
long
till we get that fuel
that tractor's not moving
which means the big fields don't get
plowed and the yield comes in short
what about the plow we brought back from
the museum i need a blacksmith to fix it
i don't have one right now
how long is earl going to be locked up
i don't know
i haven't decided first time we've had
to deal with something like this it
might be time then
start talking about making some rules
do you think he'd ever do something like
this again i didn't think that he'd do
it the first time well you didn't hang
him like you did gregory there must be a
reason for that so should i let him walk
like nothing happened no
i hate what he did to you
to enid
but if keeping him locked up means that
the crops don't get planted then it's
not just him that gets better the
hilltop will be fine
until that ethanol shows up we're
holding on to our surplus it's because
we're gonna need him
number nine olivia benson law and order
svu
in the criminal justice system sexually
based offenses are considered especially
heinous in new york city the dedicated
detectives who investigate these vicious
felonies are members of an elite squad
known as the special victims unit led by
a fierce woman who is single-mindedly
focused on bringing perpetrators to
justice olivia benson is so
inspirational that her crusade for
victims has spilled over into marishka
hargitay's real life the actress is a
leading activist dedicated to ending the
rape kit backlog and has helped fight
for sexual assault survivors with her
joyful heart foundation now 15 years
into his mission to change society's
response to sexual assault domestic
violence and child abuse
he doing great guys
it's okay nice and easy
get back
move
get back
now farther back
wait for the green light
your kids are going in the back of the
car you know joe
joe we don't really
we don't really need the kids anymore
right you keep your gun on me
why don't we let the kids go
and just make it about you and me joe
i'm all you need
you and me
go
go
he's letting both kids go okay that's
great joe come on thank you joe all
right come on come on keep going keep
going
keep going
get in okay
i'm getting it
i'm just gonna let tucker know the plan
okay
no i'm gonna tell tucker take him out
secure his weapon i got it
number eight isa insecure
as a los angeles thirty-something
navigating personal and professional
relationships alongside her best friends
rey portrays an everyday kind of
fearlessness the kind required to
confront your own decisions good and bad
and move forward with them and maybe
dance a little in the mirror while
you're at it
i saw lauren send his new girlfriend the
other day what
what'd you do i said hello uh got my to
go and kept pushing him he looked really
happy so
you good
because that have activated me on petty
i mean
i'd be lying if i said it didn't bother
me a little bit
we were together for five years yeah you
ain't been broken up that long
i don't know
but the person he is now is not the
person he was with me what do you mean
like they were out to the lungs and i'm
pretty sure he was going to pay
i never got that that's true
yes
i don't know i got that with potential
you know i got the work in progress and
it took a lot of support and patience
and
i just
i feel like
she's reaping all the benefits of his
time with me
yeah
let me shut up because i know i don't
have a right to feel like that nah you
have a right to feel however you want to
feel
seriously
number seven the doctor doctor who
season 11. the story of doctor who a
time traveling extraterrestrial life
form who acts as a sort of space-time
cop battling intergalactic and alternate
universe threats and occasionally
regenerating took what is arguably its
most profound turn yet with its 13th
doctor for the first time since the
iconic british sci-fi series began
airing in 1963 the doctor regenerated as
a woman whitaker took on more than just
a staple of british pop culture when she
agreed to play the role but also its
rabid fan base so hats off to the doctor
and her new adventurers as well as a
brave woman who accepted the gig
so everything we saw everything we've
lied to people about
is this normal for you
i'm just a traveler sometimes i see
things need fixing
i do what i can
except right now
i'm a traveler without a ship
i've stayed too long i should get back
to finding what's hardest doctor
can i just say
you really need to get out of those
clothes
right yeah
it's been a long time since i bought
women's clothes
[Music]
yes now that's what i want
[Music]
that's what you're going with
yep
got any cash empty pockets
also
i've been thinking about my tardis do
you think you guys might be able to help
me
[Music]
number six captain giorgio and michael
burnham star trek discovery
since its start in the 1960s the star
trek franchise has grown both in size
and in socio-political philosophy now
part of that growth hit streaming
service cbs all-access in 2018 with
season 1 of star trek discovery which
focuses on the struggles of a female
crew member of its starship with male
captains playing a supporting role to
her main storyline martin green's
burnham is the thread connecting an
otherwise ensemble cast it features yo
as both earnest upstanding captain
giorgio and her indomitable alt universe
counterpart emperor giorgio
your life will be long gabriel
and every single moment of it will be
spent in our agonizers
a fair price to pay for your vaulting
ambition
take him to break c only the finest for
our new guests
you could have died hunting that traitor
across the universe
i
am so happy
you didn't
let her rest a bit and have her at my
residence by dinner yes emperor
there is so much to discuss
everything
will be the way it was
dear daughter
number five courtney whitmore dc's star
girl
whether moving to a new town in nebraska
learning how to fly or convincing people
that being better is worthwhile
courtney's courage is wrapped up in a
surprisingly sunny optimism for a
teenager who supposedly grew up in
southern california nevertheless it
makes her a compelling lead as it proves
to be infectious among the friends that
she makes and the viewers at home and if
you remember how hard it was to get a
club in high school off the ground or
for that club to make the simplest
decision courtney's ability to resurrect
the justice society of america with a
handful of outcast teens is a superpower
in its own right
[Music]
uh
no way
[Music]
where are you
[Music]
like the dogs throwing up marshmallows
all
number four women of the expanse
each of the space opera's principal
female leads kicks major ass in her own
way naomi nagata an equal partner in
ownership and operation of the
rosannante and brilliant engineer with a
heart of gold christian of asurala the
foul-mouthed planet leader who mops the
floor with condescending politicians
bobby draper the former mars marine
corps gunnery sergeant who now uses her
very particular set of skills to help
save the solar system and last but not
least kamina drummer the belter captain
and former security chief who later
makes a living as a space pirate
[Music]
i know that look on your face
don't do this
naomi
please
i can fix this with marco
you don't have to not follow me
[Music]
[Music]
number three hannah
she's a teenage assassin with major
daddy issues when they cooked up hannah
in the lab they sort of broke the mold
in this amazon prime video adaptation of
the feature film we come to find out
that hannah isn't alone she was part of
a legion of designer killers raised from
birth but with special training from her
father however she may be the deadliest
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
number two siri and yennefer the witcher
amidst the magical creatures of the
witcher siri and yennefer reign in
season one young syria was just learning
about her deadly powers while yennefer
journeyed from physically disabled farm
girl to one of the realm's most powerful
sorceresses
[Music]
take her instead
[Music]
there's a sacrifice
[Music]
[Music]
uh
um
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions the next chand
the book of boba fett the mandalorian
brought three amazing women into its
second season although we met fenech
shand in the first season we really only
saw her brilliance in a battle and her
sense of honor recently and after
watching her take out some imperials we
definitely want her in our squad now
with the mandalorian spin-off show the
book of boba fett we can't wait to see
what fanec does this time around
i know that you sit on the throne of
your former employer
jabber ruled with fear
[Music]
i intend to rule with respect
you were all once captains under jabba
the hutt
i'm here to make a proposal that's
mutually beneficial
[Music]
[Applause]
why speak of conflict
when cooperation can make us all rich
what prevents us all from killing you
and taking what we want
if you had spoken such insolence to
jabba
he'd have fed you to his menagerie
please
speak freely
[Music]
claire randall outlander
time-traveling wife claire not only has
to contend with the mind-blowing fact
that she slipped 200 years through time
from the 1940s to the relatively
barbaric 1740s but also that her
husband's doppelganger in that time is a
twisted rapist but claire endures and
endures and endures through violent
attacks and the tragic deaths of loved
ones nevertheless she persisted
i see we're all ready to go
mata please try not to insult too many
people tonight
[Music]
are you
mad woman
you can see every inch of you right down
to your third rib
no you can't
christ
i can see your identity on naval sure
you don't mean to go out in public like
this i most certainly do i'll have you
know i helped design this dress
it's not an egg
first your honeypot nevertheless
i'll wait in the carriage no you won't
i suppose it'll have to do
could cover it up a bit i already
thought of that
[Music]
and finally number one emily dickinson
dickinson emily dickinson was more than
a recluse who kept her poetry mostly
hidden from the world during her
lifetime and in haley steinfeld's
embodiment of her in the eponymous apple
tv plus series one gets to see a modern
take on what the writer's life was like
in this show there's twerking romance
with her sister-in-law carriage rides
with death and a natural inclination to
fight her mother's expectations that she
marry a proper young man when i married
austin and we became sisters the only
bond between us was your words you
started writing so much and i was the
only one
who ever saw any of it
i got overwhelmed
so i thought if i pushed you
a little
if you pushed me away i'd become someone
else's problem
well
guess what
i'm not your problem anymore sue
you can go back to your perfect parlor
with your fancy dresses and be as
exquisitely empty as you like because i
will never make you feel anything again
and without me
what
without me
i don't think you know how to have
feelings
okay
shut the door on your way out
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love and
until next time i'm your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you